hey what's going on everybody before we
go ahead and start the the meat of this
video I keep saying that that's not the
phrase I want to talk to you guys
quickly about this company that came to
me called better and help better help is
a way for you to get affordable private
online counseling you can get access to
licensed trained fully accredited
therapists and counselors there like
LGBTQ friendly religious non-religious
this is all up to you and that's really
great for even like couple counseling if
you want to sign up for this you guys
already know you just have to hit that
link in the description box below fill
out a questionnaire and they will match
you with a counselor today yes it's that
quick and if you want to talk about
pricing it's way more affordable than
in-person counseling and on top of that
you can actually get financial aid for
it if you qualify pricing is between
thirty five dollars to sixty five
dollars a week for unlimited counseling
this means that you are connected to a
counselor the entire time via like a
phone or a computer and you can schedule
a videophone or text sessions when
necessary usually about once per week
what better help the cool thing is
you're not really wasting your time
traveling to a counselor and if you're
not really vibing with the counselor
that you have you could switch him at
any time you want and for me the best
part about this is that you could
actually connect to a counselor from
home and probably one of the biggest
reasons why people don't even go to
counseling is because they're not used
to that that personal one-on-one thing
so it kind of opens up a new way for you
to get the counseling you need without
like the traditional way of doing like
for example let's say like you're having
a session with a counselor and you start
crying and you're not really comfortable
with being vulnerable with somebody
enough to where you can cry for them you
could actually turn the video part off
and you could continue to talk that
person on the phone it makes it very
comfortable for you and easy for you for
those of you who aren't used to this now
obviously before mentioning better help
I actually went on the app and I tried
using it myself and signing up because
it gave me a quick demo and it's really
really easy and is very very
self-explanatory you fill out the
questionnaire and they match you over
the counselor that day so if you guys do
want online counseling just hit that
link in the description box below and
after you guys use this let me know what
you thought about it and let me know if
it helped you out
[Music]
hey what's going on yet
you're [ __ ] panty sniffers oh darling
how do you so why don't you sniff
panties people what is that about
welcome to another episode of podcast
yes laughs I was thinking about calling
a thought cast but if when you call it
thought cats it sounds like I'm talking
about some hos
so I was thinking to myself today while
I was gone and people were messaging me
kind of like where I'm at and what I'm
doing and you know just I was really
absent from social media aside from like
Instagram and stuff like that I wanted
to grab specifically a question that a
subscriber was asking but this is a
question that a lot of subscribers ask
and I didn't realize people thought this
about me when they saw my content on my
channel aside from the fact that I'm a
rude [ __ ] a lot of people ask this
question David how do you always stay
happy and the widow thing is like I
don't know exactly how to address that
because who says I'm always happy I
think what we watch people that we
idolize they only show us like the great
things about their life look at this
yacht I'm on but you don't my cool
friends look at my expensive stuff cool
story bro must be nice
I bought a Honda Element badge
[Music]
she broke down on me four times [ __ ]
that thing I love it so much I named my
Honda Element hood papi because that
shit's not dependable doesn't really
work in it's never around when you need
him the most I guess I were to give you
some advice it would be broken down into
two things when it comes to the topic of
happiness number one your idols will
rarely ever show you the real trials and
tribulations that go on in their life
but most importantly why because one of
the biggest reasons is because a lot of
people don't gravitate toward sadness
and it's not really brand friendly not
really not knocking on people for doing
that I'm just saying that when you watch
these people who tell you that their
lives are great and happy all the time
they're not really out there to express
the bad things that go on in their life
and it's not that responsibility to do
it either online content is made for
entertainment it's not a basis of
reality but even for somebody like me I
don't share you guys all the trials and
tribulations that I go through why
because I don't think it's any of your
business and I don't think it's
something that I want to share with
everybody either me saying it's none of
your business means that there are
certain things that I should keep
private not just want to but should keep
private
within my group that doesn't deserve to
be told to everybody in the world so
these people that you look up to that
show you only the positive things in
life it's not a true reflection of
what's going on remember when I put up
that video when I was talking about me
taking a break I've done that a few
times but you know I didn't tell you all
the little small things that led up to
that point where I just [ __ ] snapped
when it came to my mental health and you
guys didn't know about the house [ __ ]
drowning and like I mentioned before I
was going through something that it was
my biggest fear like I was waking up
every day without a purpose and I was
[ __ ] scared shitless
so I bounced I disappeared and I worked
on myself really really hard and and the
first thing that I did was lose his
weight like I told you that in the video
I said I was gonna lose his weight and
get a grasp but my [ __ ] life and I
did which is why I'm back on this space
but a lot of people you know said this
[ __ ] to me yo you should document
every time you lose like 5 pounds and do
like a time-lapse of your weight loss
myth [ __ ] - yes I'm not sitting here
trying to record every step of the way
because number one I wasn't even sure if
I could do it and number two
by doing that [ __ ] that was a myself
for a second goddamn my everything's
about you [ __ ] selfish but going back
to my point what I'm saying is is that
look at your idols and look at the
people that you look up to or the
accounts that you follower the people
that you watch on TV as a source of
entertainment or maybe even like a
source of inspiration but don't think
for one [ __ ] second that you are
seeing everything about their lives we
are choosing what you get to see about
our lives happiness isn't something that
you search for in somebody else's life
you got to search for that in your own
life you why do you always forget how
[ __ ] important it is to work on
yourself and this kind of leads to the
number two part did you guys [ __ ]
know did you actually know happiness
takes effort what yeah you simpleton
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] I'm not just
saying this to you I'm talking to myself
right now
happiness takes effort it actually takes
work to be happy
but did you realize it did you actually
[ __ ] internalize this that a lot of
the things that are worth fighting for
takes effort that includes your
happiness and we could even expand all
this even more you bitch-ass
[ __ ] perspective helps out a
lot with my happiness dude you guys know
I have some of the worst [ __ ] luck on
earth just in general and people have
witnesses to like even Vanessa my spine
my former assistant slash producer let
me tell you about this story real quick
I just got my Tesla back not too long
ago right and Tycho was born this day do
you little Tycho you parking to the
hospital
I see GOI give her a hug a kiss on the
cheek everything is great the new baby
is born I'm hugging Bart whatever on my
way out
right I'm leaving the parking lot and
there is just just half broken pillar
that my sensor on my Tesla couldn't see
I backed right into it it crushed the
side of my back rear bumper and I was
just like back and I just got the car
back after like seven or eight months
after it got smashed into a big ring by
the way God so I'm going to get my car
fixed at a local body shop I park the
car and as I park I hear a boom and my
mark starts rattling guess what happened
after just getting back from hitting a
big rig gets backed into by a big rig
what are the [ __ ] chances what are
the [ __ ] chances that I would get hit
by a big rig twice and sometimes it
wasn't my fault
and normally I'm a terrible driver but
my car was part so like the Mexican
homie walks out he looks at my car and
she just goes oh shoot my bear foo
oh [ __ ] my dad for my back so we
exchange our information right and I
[ __ ] you not and check this picture out
the dude showed me his license right and
I'm gonna blow out his [ __ ] face but
if you look at his eyes he has one dead
eye and he's driving a big rig and on
his license it says 2020 that is the
type of luck that I have [ __ ] like this
happens to me 24 [ __ ] 7 I don't know
how I don't know why you what my life is
my life is a [ __ ] final destination
but Satan you ain't getting me Jesus
right when the car gets hit like I'm
sitting there and then Vanessa looks at
me and asks do you have like the worst
luck in the world how do you deal with
this so calmly and this kind of goes
back into happiness takes effort meaning
that it's a lot about perspective a lot
of people keep telling you like yo man
everything should be good things should
be happy when when when bad things
happen it's just the whole world against
us you [ __ ] that advice that advice is
so [ __ ] dumb this is what it is
bad things are supposed to happen in
your life you should be mentally
prepared for them that doesn't mean life
sucks it means [ __ ] [ __ ] happens I
need to make a shirt that says bad [ __ ]
it happens you guys are so used to
people telling you what you know what
King you know what Queen you deserve the
world which you [ __ ] do but it
doesn't exempt you from the fact that
bad things are gonna happen and you
should prepare yourself for that because
it's going to make life so much happier
and easier for you people who get torn
down from the smallest things like they
walk around and they slip on something
and they go oh my God my life is over
then [ __ ] your bitch-ass kneecaps you
punk [ __ ] you deserve to cry and you
deserve to mope completed because all
you're complaining about dumb [ __ ]
there's a few people in this world that
are dealt with an amazing deck of cards
but even those people who are
born into money and are rich they got
their own [ __ ] set of problems they
don't know what they want to do in their
lives because everything has been given
for them they just sit there with their
Lambert you know what this actually
sounds pretty nice everybody's going
through their own personal issues all
the time men your happiness takes effort
you have to work on being happy and
guess what when you find out what makes
you happy and you keep working on it and
then five years later it disappears
that's normal what makes you happy now
is going to change and later on you're
gonna have to work on it again and find
your happiness again that's life and you
know what that's the exciting part about
life things constantly change you have
to adapt to it and that actually was is
what makes me excited like I don't want
to just be content doing one thing for
the rest of my life and because I know
happiness takes effort I welcome that
challenge because every time I search
for it and I find it again and again and
again it feels just as good as the first
time when I found my first type of
happiness which was food in vagina this
is the stuff that I had to think about
and work on when I was on my break and I
really wanted to share this with you
guys because man had to go through some
[ __ ] and I don't want to call it
depression just because like I don't
want to make light of what other people
go through when they are like clinically
depressed I was sad and I had to dig
myself out of this hole with the help of
my friends and Vanessa I love that
little girl to death you know she's like
my baby sister and she was there with me
every step of the way when I was doing
these walks to help me lose weight she
was there to help me laugh and help me
function and you know on top of that tip
I also had my girlfriend who was oh my
god but I can't even tell you how
supportive she was that was my form of
counseling and I realized that not a lot
of people have that to which just to go
back to this to better help that's what
like counseling is for it's not to make
you feel like you're a crazy person but
sometimes you just need people to talk
to and that's why I'm working with this
company right now to even put this in
this video but anyways guys gals and
your sexy little [ __ ] yeah I like your
legs they're nice and smooth and if it's
hairy but you guys already know the
drill by now comments below let me know
the type of stuff that you guys want to
see in these question there so I can
answer articles or topics or whatever
you guys want let's have a discussion
yes love you [ __ ] let's tackle life
together and let's be strong I [ __ ]
love
man open mouth kiss me right now and
normally I'm a terrible driver but I was
my powers cart my car was parked I drink
a boost for breakfast to Asia for
dessert
somebody order pancakes I just sit the
scissor what song is that from hint